welcome to this video G&K 1230 yep
recently played the sky oops come on I
really want to place your phone oh we
got a-what do we get stone wall or a
classical Dutch that looks more like the
classical lunch yep yeah that's an
opening i really need to study I mean
not that it is super frequently seen but
it's the kind of opening that is tricky
of you I really don't have the recipe
against and what I'm playing is kind of
yeah okay it doesn't really yeah it's
not really a great concept or anything I
know that this exists with before but I
don't know if it is any good or should
be played in in this some this kind of
move autumn and move orders are
typically very important than those
closed openings I had had almost the
same position recently against endless
fighter a pretty good GM oh no it was it
was very very similar stuff you went
with Knight a5 I remember that
what a strange position
Jem that's a very difficult very
difficult to play it's kind of kind of
unusual this is this whole structure
this is not so much I mean okay he takes
it I was intending to put it on d3 it's
not not happened okay here i get the g
four square that was my was one idea
very difficult this pollution and as
mentioned unconventional never seen
anything like that with a four played
and so on I shouldn't be in bad shape
but it's some yeah it's not really
self-evident what to do I guess this is
one of the advantages of playing this
this line it is kind of it is not easy
to play and people are not white players
I mean are not used to those some used
to this position types in some mum and
some other openings let's say everybody
end and the uncle and they have they
have some kind of plan yeah I mean
everybody knows that I don't know the
minority attack or something but what to
do here is really not that serve evident
ok I take six you might take f2 right oh
ok
this is useful post anyway for this look
not sure maybe 96 bishop f2 wasn't
impossible but rupee one looks sensible
anyway intending maybe Bishop a one
asking this Queen where to go
I wonder no I never really threaten f3
is has 95 it's the only square but it is
one still something to take into account
okay yeah well f3 looks amazingly ugly
but f 395 age for how is he saving this
piece he just has taken the square
square away okay I hang over it as ugly
as it looks with this diagonal but still
what is he doing now some kind of
miracle check check yeah I mean this
kind of f 2 pieces b6 on c5 are on my
one like sensitive diagonal here so
there they can always they can always
some can be some kind of weird tactic
but I really don't see anything d 4 is
quite nicely protected and i also have
III so if he just decides to give up the
night for a no-look the aid takes fe d
you for I have III really cementing the
d4 night I think it's really just a
piece
black resign yeah it's really just a
piece nine th form and that's it yeah
add it is really a difficult difficult
position up to here I'm pretty confident
that this should be quite okay what I
did I mean I don't really see much
alternatives if once i went for before I
mean here I mean maybe I can play
without a three but I don't see how yeah
this is the the annoying point of blacks
play ok c 6 p.m. txt x 92 looks totally
normal you went t5 yeah it's what a
strange position one point is that black
sometimes has Knight a5 we can use those
light squares and well cd5 is not a move
that I'm really totally confident that
this is good that wasn't I wasn't really
sure my idea was to put this night back
on d3 this knight on f3 but it didn't
really matter because he took it only
five went here oh this looks very normal
okay here here the computer is already
saying that is a big mistake because of
that no other compass giving III hmm
yeah okay beach was hanging but e6 of
course is also hanging so maybe III boss
was a bit more to the point but I don't
think it's a huge difference ah there is
a difference black now could have played
f4 very interesting move I am okay so
III was bet I am I mean computer also
says that I'm better here but hmm 0.8
and it's it's kind of crazy maybe a
little bit
okay I can do this Queen moves and then
f3 or III yeah that's actually quite
likely that i would have played that and
this is still pretty good for wine yeah
maybe it doesn't matter very much out
yet he blundered the PSM what can you do
yeah there was a kind of a sudden end to
this game but ok go to winning yeah
thanks for watching